diese entdeckung verblüfft expertinnen
und experten weltweit denn ein
eigentlich gewöhnliches mineral hat sich
in einem experiment eines
forschungsteams als ein extrem haben
muss sagen seltsamer supraleiter
herausgestellt konkret geht es um eine
uran verbindung die gleich zwei
verschiedene supraleiter phasen aufweist
was ist da also geheimnisvolles los
krieg schon science fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
diese erkenntnis ist wirklich eine
krasse überraschung für die gesamte
fachwelt dabei hatte das os
forschungsteam eigentlich ein anderes
ziel
ursprünglich ging es den fachleuten
darum eine völlig andere uran
verbindungen herzustellen
doch das experiment ging schief und es
entstanden kristalle von uran tiger lou
reed gute 2 in der fachwelt ist diese
verbindung als supraleiter bekannt der
eine ungewöhnliche spin anordnung der
elektronen paare aufweist wenn das ist
der dreh impuls eines sich drehenden
objektes also die energie die in der
drehung enthalten ist und die zum
beispiel bei einem kreise enthalten es
bei teilchen ist der festtag
unabänderliche bestandteil und hat werte
wie ein halb oder 1 zum beispiel als
supraleiter bezeichnet man materialien
die strom widerstands freileitung
beispielsweise wie sk fehler oder
bestimmte metallhydrid tun möglich wird
das durch die zusammenlagerung von
elektronen im kristallgitter diese
schließen sich zu paaren zusammen und
zwar mit einer speziellen ausrichtung
des spiels schnell zeigte sich dass zwar
das eigentliche experiment nicht
geglückt war dafür aber ein super
exotischer supraleiter entdeckt worden
konnte denn uran tiger lou reed besitzt
nicht nur eine supraleitende phase
sondern gleich zwei das us
forschungsteam war baff und analysierte
das material genauer und kühlte es dabei
bis auf knapp über dem absoluten
nullpunkt herunter dann untersuchten sie
seine leitfähigkeit und sorgten für
magnetfelder in seiner umgebung dabei
gewannen sie erstaunliche erkenntnisse
wenn der kristall sich nämlich in einem
bestimmten winkel zum magnetfeld
befindet tritt die erste phase der
supraleitung auf bis zu 35
kessler hält die widerstands- freie
stromleitung an und das ist echt nicht
ohne zum besseren vergleich diese stärke
von 35 tesla ist viermal so viel wie der
magnet am teilchenbeschleuniger lhc also
dem größten teilchenbeschleuniger der
welt am cern in genf aufweist eine
wirklich außergewöhnliche eigenschaft
der normalerweise mögen supraleiter
keine starken externe magnetfelder dazu
der wissenschaftler schenken rang der an
dem experiment beteiligt war sondern
ganz seltenen fällen führen magnetfelder
zum gegenteiligen effekt und
stabilisieren die supraleitung sogar
doch nicht nur die wirklich
ungewöhnliche stabilität gegenüber der
magnet einwirkung überraschte denn als
das forschungsteam den kristall drehte
und das magnetfeld weiter erhöhte trat
eine zweite phase der supraleitung auf
konkret war das bei rund 40 tesla der
fall
dazu schreibt das autorenteam in der
studie der maximalwert lag bei mehr als
65 tesla dem stärksten in unseren
messungen erzeugt bahrenfeld eine
wiederkehrende supraleitung bei so hohen
feldstärken ist bisher nun gemessen
worden
eine echte weltpremiere also die die
fachleute als großen erfolg feiern an
material bei dem zwei verschiedenen
supraleitende phasen hintereinander
auftreten konnte bislang noch nie
aufgespürt werden in anlehnung an die
bibel nennen die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler dieses phänomen den
lazarus effekt denn die super
leitfähigkeit stirbt ja quasi zuerst ab
bevor sie dann wieder aufersteht eine
wirklich exotische eigenschaft da sich
die beiden phasen der supra
leitfähigkeit wohl voneinander
unterscheiden
nach ansicht der fachleute stecken zwei
unterschiedliche mechanismen dahinter
dazu der physik iap ohne der an der
studie beteiligt war
dies ist wirklich ein bemerkenswertes
material uran tiger lou reed hat
wahrscheinlich noch weitere
überraschungen auf lager die fachleute
setzen also große hoffnungen auf diese
verbindung möglicherweise könnte das
uran thiele dorit sogar eine
entscheidende rolle bei der entwicklung
von quantencomputern spielen denn
supraleitende materialien gelten als
basis für die quantenbits courante der
logik könnte somit als eine
vielversprechende komponente von
quantencomputer dienen an den
forschungsteams weltweit derzeit tüfteln
sie können ja jetzt schon nach dem
durchbruch durch google bestimmte
aufgaben in wien
berechnen für die herkömmliche
supercomputer 10.000 jahre bräuchten die
quanten überlegenheit ist damit durch
google erreicht worden wir hatten ja
darüber berichtet alles über
quantencomputer anklicken anschaut und
doktor watson kostenlos abonnieren
super kanal mit hammer videos bis dann
bleibt dran